let's do it and okay ladies and
gentlemen welcome to another episode
ever
[Music]
one of the funniest comics out there and
one of my best friends in the world and
honestly
[Applause]
in a business at snow- I'll just play
the airbase
[Music]
we're little kids that don't have any
other friends all the cool kids have
rocks in their hands and like when your
parents garage you know to me you know
you can see you can take them over you I
use them that's exactly what this isn't
and your mom comes in with peanut butter
jelly sandwiches it's to lunch on kids
don't cut the crusts off
but anyways dude thanks for coming out
you know I've been on your podcast and
uh I started this thing and I said you
know I got to get everybody I know that
I admire and that kind of stuff on here
you are you know a very funny guy you
know you're always you're so positive
and a business is so negative you know
and by the way make sure you check out
Steve's album what's the name of the
album
Jaba Jaba you know what I mean it's
called Jabba it was it was doing very
well when it first came out on iTunes I
think it still doing well hit number one
stay there three weeks ago
and I think it just fell out of there
like top couple spots this week so
that's great so make sure you listen to
that if you if you listen especially
like I said I can't reiterate this
enough if you're tired of like just the
negative negativity of comedy and you
want to hear something like you know fun
and positive this is the guy for that
and always ask is that like was that
like a choice yeah was a choice for me
and my own mental health to be arrived
here cuz I don't I don't think I'm any
different than any other comic or
whatever but I just made the choice to
start celebrating what to have a little
more gratitude on my comedy because I
needed that my life ah interesting you
know what I mean like it's for me and
then hopefully the audience takes it too
it's like your own healing process
absolutely yeah I know I know cuz like
for me I mean I go negative it's not
necessary
this is what's pissing me off or like
yeah this is what I feel about a certain
thing and I'll talk about it that way
because that's just my I also think it's
like it's um it can be the funniest side
of my personality yeah you know what I
mean so that's nice I often go to that
but you know like I say I've see again I
watch you and you're just like you
like you said it's funny how you put it
celebrating you know God I took I had I
needed that myself right we're go our
job is to tell the truth and then I'm
like alright well if this is the truth
of life why are any of us here so I got
to keep on digging and then when I
started to keep on digging and digging
I'm like wait there's some amazing stuff
in life and let's celebrate that and
let's focus on that
yeah I guess I know what you're saying
I guess what I was referring to is that
like I guess comedy can be so
therapeutic mm-hmm and so you know like
when things are bothering you
there's like a certain sense of like hey
talk about this right now because this
is what's bothering you yeah and then
what you're doing is like well this is
bothering me but I can heal yeah right
yeah like there's a bit on the new album
where one of my friends pointed out
who's a comic he was like dude that's a
freakishly dark bit but you made it
funny and it's about my dad almost
giving my older brother the beating of
his life right but he was too fat to
take his belt off so we all just had
laughs and that's kind of how I view
life like is there a darkness there
absolutely but there's also a joy in in
the suffering there's a joy in the
moment and it's like hey man it goes by
so fast
find something celebrate find something
to it cuz that's it that's what we got
that kind of happened to me my mom there
was this tree outside in the backyard in
RTN you know and literally my mom would
be like go get a switch off that tree
and that's how that's how I would get
whooped you know I mean so what kind of
psychological because you can't pick a
little bit oh really how about if I use
the bat instead and then there used to
be like a hallway in my this apartment
we lived in where like so there was like
a door at the end and if you walked
through the hallway it was like the
length of the apartment and you could
come in you know so it was like a long
way around nobody was like a roundabout
yeah you know so it was like so I would
run from my mom we would run in circles
she would be chasing me fun times
because
the middle of the running we both
started laughing that's what happened
with my dad was too fast to get his belt
off look I never saw my fat big brother
ever run he rag and the whole family my
dad's chasing my brother and then the
rest of the family's chasing my dad
chasing my moms like Jesus don't kill
him
I know we did a couple laps from like
living rooms through the kitchen through
the dining room through the kitchen
through the run and my dad finally got
him cornered and he was too fat to get
the belt off so so again like a surround
for my mom but so the one night days I'm
really in trouble I don't know I
remember of course I remember what I did
but she's like go get a switch off the
tree
I go out back and the trees gone they
thank you Jesus I know they they cut the
tree down and so I have to go back I go
but I was like I was scared because I
was like the trees gone she starts
cracking up you know one of the first
times I was like you know this humor
thing something to dislike making people
laugh to get out of [ __ ] yeah and yeah
I'll never forget that and then it was
like that was one of them I don't know
do you remember the lap like I remember
the last time that like spankings it
wasn't gonna work anymore this one like
I was at a certain age where my mom's
trying to hit me and I'm just looking at
her like wow you know Oh mom this is
really your you know my mom's most
powerful weapon in her whole arsenal
which still has leverage on me was
always her just going well well my mom
came from Central America so you know it
was like whooping czar nothing I
remember my mom like she was just like
what was ever in arms reach like ever
once on a family vacation easily my
older brother get most of it that's my
eye on me I saw the vicious beatings and
I was just like - do I have to get what
do I gotta sit well alright I'm good no
problems whatever hurts just looking and
she took a hairbrush and smacked it on
his fat ass and bro
cut in half yeah and we all started
laughing why I don't know why beatings
and laughing yeah you your family's
guineas you know we're a lot of emotion
yes oh yeah
in my mom yeah my mom I just remember I
can remember being like 15 or 16 it just
you know you just physically stronger
now you know yeah I just being like okay
can you sort out how did that dynamic
change in terms of her Authority and
house you know
actually if I can remember being a kid
it's like we had a lot of knock out like
yelling matches at that point you know
but what do you put but you know that's
just teen hormones just like it I don't
know how parents deal with that
especially today I don't know like house
to me are all superheroes because at
every stage is somebody's life
you're the most imply that I mean that
connection that responsibility I don't
know how do they do it like I did a CD a
couple years ago I know the premise was
that I was playing with little kids or
kind of gangsters like they want what
they want or else everybody's gonna have
a problem like my three four year old
nephews and I'm like that's a handful
but now I'm starting to watch the
teenagers in Iraq oh it's even worse and
I'm like how do they cuz they're not
even cute anymore yeah like at least a
little guy it's pretty funny when
they're when they're bad but like a zit
face 15 year old that's I guess to door
never 2 to 4 they're like hot chicks in
Hollywood you know I know and then
there's like there's the whole concept
of like a village to raise a kid is not
happening anymore because when I was a
kid when I was a kid if I got in trouble
at school the thing that got me to like
not continue whatever the [ __ ] I was
doing was them going I'm gonna call your
mom
yes you know they said we're gonna call
your mom and then I'll be like alright
let's talk this through like we don't
need to do that dude I remember once
when I was 13 so I was in that awful
face and me my skateboarder buddies
we're trying to the end thing was to try
to do a nollie up onto a wall and do
some sort of wall thing right so we're
on the side of a gas station inside of a
garage and skateboard marks are all over
the wall and this guy comes out and
breaks balls so all my friends just sort
of scram but the one guy said I know you
what's your last
I know your father so I was like man so
they all laugh yeah and part of it was
the fear of physical repercussions but
it was more like even as a kid I was a
sensitive kid I knew the struggles my
parents were going through and keep a
roof over our head I know I knew how
miserable their lives were and I just
didn't want to add to that that must be
terrible to have that knowledge as a kid
I had it from the earliest my hurl is I
never had that bliss say when people say
ignorance is bliss this is exactly what
I'm talking about man like I would hear
my dad waking up and going to work I'm
like I don't want to do that you
remember one time I was like doing a
show in like Oklahoma or something like
that
some weird like you know you have to get
in a rental car and drive like you know
for your life like you're not sure where
the [ __ ] you are I'm at this weird hotel
place and like there's a lot of military
guys there and after the show I'm kind
of you know what do I have to do so I'll
you know I'm hanging out with these
military kids young guys - yeah they are
you know they're in their 20s you know
but one of them the guy was a field
medic Oh superhero yeah he was a legit
superhero and you know and he was like
it's funny you say that because I felt
just but here's the thing he was fully
aware you know what I mean like he was
like the guy that like he knew what he
was doing dude they're better people you
know like I had a very ignorant
perspective of what the military was
until I started to do shows overseas and
I remember first off I thought everybody
had a gun in their hand I thought
everybody was a little green army man I
didn't realize how many people are there
to support the efforts of those boots on
the ground oak on Sept of anything but
then in the back of my brain because
I've always been sort of patriotic Simon
ATS kids I grew up with Hulk Hogan you
know what I mean Rambo movies they've
always been superheroes to me but I'm
gonna be honest remember when I was 18
and I was trying to discern things and
I'm gone I don't know if I could take
orders from somebody dude the people
I've met in the military there just cut
from a different cloth they're better
people like I've met people I'm like oh
i'd follow that guy in the battle I
trust that dude with my life they're
just they have a sense of awareness that
well this but see but this is this is
what I'm trying to say though is that
this guy was
like that yeah what you're saying yeah
cuz again he's a field medic he but he
knew that like he was like is almost as
if he knew the dangers of war and he was
there to help support in the aftermath
right now his buddy his buddy was this
dude that was like he would like one
through a brick wall for you right yeah
but this guy was like but I could tell
how just ignorant this guy was about
just what he was doing the life he was
living but he just was like this is my
man and I saw the other guy and I could
tell how responsible yeah this the field
medic guy felt for him absolutely
because he saw that he was like man this
I have to make sure cuz this is the kind
of guy that would be like if some [ __ ]
broke out he would he's the first guy
there he's the first guy like you know
you know and I just thought man so I'm
saying you were that guy for your
brothers and sisters or you know you
don't mean that you were the guy that
was like you know what I don't want to
get dad involved in this because there
and then like there's this sort of
entitlement that kids have you know
that's what I'm saying they're kind of
like hot chicks in LA this kind of
entitlement of like like I deserve the
world you know it's a form of ignorance
yeah and that's where I mean I remember
being like that when I you know it was a
kid just you know you just want what you
want you know my mom man when you look
back at the things that you cuz I
remember that going on my birthday's my
mom promised a she was gonna take a few
of my friends to Magic Mountain Wow
her car broke down yeah you know but I
don't understand God betrayal dude I
can't believe it in the car oh my that's
what moms yeah she rented a car and I
look back on I can't appreciate it till
now correct that was you took the scent
you just did one of those whip older
I've gotten the more I appreciate the
sacrifices that were made to try to make
me happy yeah and I feel an obligation
to repay that directly to my parents but
also live my life in a way that makes
them proud so we're okay so where you
from originally suburban Philadelphia
Saburo suburban so it's a separate thing
yeah oh you know why cuz Philly people
will break your balls if you go Philly
they're like you ain't from Philly
yeah Chicago people like that too
because Chicago is so big a lot of
people like to say they're from Chicago
but they're like 25 miles from the city
right I grew up like I used to work in
the city after college and would take me
15 minutes
so about train or something car Oh car
okay yeah it was I believe was a car
town it's in everything town yeah this
trains like actually of the people that
know how to live life they get a nice
house on the suburbs with a backyard and
good public schools huh
and then they drive to the train station
two minute drive leave and then take the
train into the city that's how you
really do
I guess you from Philly suburban Philly
you ain't from Philly so you from the
suburbs of Philly two brothers right
yeah I'm the middle of three boys middle
of yeah middle of my middle child yeah
and but that's why he's a comic yeah and
you had the yeah middle child or only
child
use those are the ones that become
comics so then you mother and father
like yeah tell me your story what you
know well today's actually my parents
50th wedding anniversary
oh wow they're still together 21st shout
out to them yeah and I was just so I
just got off I'm a mama's boy I just got
off the phone with my mom and I was like
I want to thank you guys for just not
giving up oh boy but she teared up
no she laughed oh you know we're more of
a laughs family so from Philly yeah yeah
like I'm like your crazy
and dad's crazy but you were crazy
enough to stick it out yeah well my
therapist always says I get yo you've
wiped me somebody you're crazy they're
crazy of them have to have to link up so
yeah I look at my parents relationship
I'm like anybody saying wouldn't put up
with my dad but then anybody sane
wouldn't put up with my mom and they
just did it and after years it since
it's just I don't think relationships
like that are gonna come around
well if you think about it like unica's
we're both in our 40s right it's like it
you ever regret like not looking back
and being like maybe when I was 31 I
should I try to get into a real relation
oh I tried I did I that's why I don't
have any regrets I did my best but our
best wasn't good enough
my fat big brother used to sing that to
my mom to make her cry it was the back
but she'd be like so what are you
getting steamed for his birthday cuz he
would shake down my mom like a gangster
he was like seriously you run around
your family man like a corrupt like a
corrupt politician right so I remember
always my little brothers Bert happy
birthday market sauce my younger
brother's birth so I ever liked say
would select my younger brothers 8th
birthday and my what this is really the
ritual of those single-digit birthdays
my big brother would have you convinced
that if he didn't go to mom on your
behalf she was gonna do your birthday
wrong so like a commercial will come on
for like a holly house like getting
protection money we gotta kick back cuz
you'd have to write something on your
birthday list for him out there he'd be
like and right in Van Halen tape this is
all real so one of his techniques before
putting the squeeze on my mom would be
like what do you get marks she's like
well we couldn't get him the GI Joe
aircraft carrier but we got him the GI
Joe combat base we got him the Aquaman
that he wanted to any go uh-huh and what
else and she be like well and then
there's like some cat huh and then what
else I'm sure that's it Christopher nigo
well you tried right I mean he goes well
you only turn 8 once and well we did our
best and here we go mm-hmm you did your
best your best wasn't good enough
they were gonna smile on Marky's face
you're rotten little boy so any laughs
your family's actually terrible terrible
and beautiful
yeah we all have we all have our things
so then when you went to school in the
public I lasted three months in Catholic
school first grade that didn't work out
so great for me really why he had a
vicious nun yeah they were bad back
there bad like I remember my favorite
thing when I was six years old to escape
the chaos of my house was I I used to
call it my tree but it was essentially
like a little bush outside that in the
front yard and I would just climb in
there and be like all right man
I'm posted up in here Wow yeah I'm good
I needed my solitude even then and then
I remember like the first day of school
this nun was like cuz you're a little
boy we'd climb trees like yeah you had a
friend that had a cool tree in his
backyard you're like it's oh yeah if you
see two branches that are yeah let me
try yeah okay then there's another way
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna get the game
yeah
and iron bird first you're six years old
you're a baby and she goes trees her to
be admired if you climb a tree you're
going to hell she was one of those
ladies so I was like I'm done yeah and
then you know public school kid middle
three boys I grew up in a way that I
thought everybody grew up and I it
wasn't until honestly I got a little
taste of it in college but didn't really
know until I moved here then I grew up
know their father not bad but I was
exposed to everybody where I grew up
uh-huh I went to school with kids that
had legit nothing all right and I also
was exposed to kids that uh like I was
on the phone with one of my buddies from
high schools dads worth like a couple
hundred million dollars so in this
public school environment I had to learn
how to get along with everybody
Oh gotcha and like my neighborhood was
primarily Jewish and Italian but even in
my neighborhood there would be like you
know a kid for a family from India a
family for Korea a family from Persia
you learned how to get along with
everybody like I remember when I went to
college I joined the BSA the black
Students Association but it wasn't a
thing yeah cuz my bar I got my buddy
Dave into the italian-american Club and
then he co-signed for me to be in the a
gave was 6-8 to 70 so though I guess
Simone's in yeah and I tried to DJ with
one turntable
it was the 90s what can I tell you but I
really thought everybody grew up with
that and then I moved out here I'm like
oh the rich kids only hung with rich
kids oh right poor kids only hung with
poor kids but right and the other thing
is how I grew up that did him because
you got to live with everybody money
didn't matter like you could hang out
with people even as adults in my 20s and
you would it be friends or friends or
friends
and you didn't even know what anybody
did you were just all watching the
Eagles yeah just kind of hanging out
yeah yeah but like here this culture in
LA whatever maybe just 2019 where people
kind of want to figure how you can help
them immediately well you know what
don't be jaded by LA ha no I think it's
I think it's more indicative of 2019 oh
then it is of the geographic location
I'm kind of I kind of feel like being in
the entertainment business you know you
find yourself around people that it's
like they're they're not trying to
cultivate relationships first they're
trying to like you know they want the
fruit from the tree you know already
yeah and it's like well you got to grow
this and you have to like right there's
a process so I think a lot of that has
to do with like because we're around a
certain business you know you did this
business because how long have you
because when did you decide that you
wanted to be a comic when I was going
through my quarter life crisis like I
remember I was a pretty good student all
things considered especially now when I
look back and I'm like oh I was dyslexic
had no idea oh wow
I didn't know until I was 40 and I was
like oh now it all makes sense like why
I felt Spanish why I could never spell
why I couldn't figure out locker like
combination locks as a kid oh wow my
brains just wired different but I was
still a pretty good student and by the
time I got the college everything really
made sense so where'd you go to college
Loyola in Baltimore oh wow I'm still
paying for it but crazy crazy absolutely
crazy but I was a good student I was in
a couple honors societies and stuff like
that and I had trouble getting a job and
then I had a corporate job that I hated
and then I said I was gonna circle back
to law school
what was the corporate job I worked for
a credit-card company called MBNA oh wow
and that was not a good fit
it was terrible yeah you were you you
would remind me of this is you're gonna
love this too by the way your you'd
totally be mr. incredible when he was
working at the insurance company you you
be these chairs and then ladies like but
I have no money and you would be like
okay here's what you told you yeah
you're not yeah you wouldn't be like oh
you couldn't be a repo guy you know it
was terrible
my fir this one I knew I had to get out
my first job the entry-level job I had
there was collecting delinquent credit
card account Oh No so there's the
philosophy that they trained you with
where they were like you're here to help
people they don't even call it
collections they called a customer
assistance so I bought into it I'm like
I'm here to help and I would spend time
with people on the phone and try to
figure out their situation and really
try to help that's not what they wanted
yeah what they wanted was you to go like
Goodfellas eff you pay me right pretty
much a number one time I was exhausted I
was sick I was having a bad day and I
started to give somebody the business on
the phone call right because they came
at me in a way that wasn't so beautiful
so when I responded out of weakness in a
way that wasn't so beautiful and from
time to time that the big shots would
listen in on your record to call yeah
and when they were listening in they
came down and gave me an award for how I
handled it oh wow I'm like oh this is
not a good match yeah because I was
embarrassed with how I behaved and they
were like it was like who's our favorite
shark oh no Steve it would be great they
would have played your phone calls to
the whole everybody you know I it's
funny you say that I had a situation
like that where like I my car I had to
call the insurance company and the lady
on the phone was trying to tell me
basically calling me a liar about what's
going on with my car and I was so mad on
the phone I was you know what I called
her back yeah I called her back right
away and I was like hi mrs. so-and-so
this is Eric Griffin calling you back
and I just I want our polish to
apologize
buddy I heard in her voice yeah that she
was like thank you yeah what's
interesting to me is when you can make
that human connection and that's
beautiful I love that what I'm starting
to find and I hope it's not the
beginning of getting jaded but what I I
really do find it I don't even think
heartbreaking is that strong of the term
yet sometimes when I get a little more
aggressive then results will come and
I'm like why is the world set up like
this it breaks my heart
what does squeaky wheel gets the oil
yeah but it's like I can't be loving and
kind and cool to everybody and you would
assume people be like oh this dude's
really cool let's try to help him that
does happen but I had in a situation
with my credit card where I bought a
hotel room through Hotwire right and
then the hotel made the mistake of
charging me in addition to me so I paid
twice for this - all right and I was
just like with the lady on I go this is
unacceptable
I go am i your customer or not you're
not treating me like a customer and I
was like you know what and she started
to give me the corporate when I go let
me talk to you sit and she can't and I
went and I dropped an f-bomb I go look
it's not you but I go let me talk to
somebody that will make me feel like an
effing customer or I'll close the
account right now I will pull out all of
my money from your bank and I'll go
somewhere that does make me feel like a
customer and then Oh
mr. small what could we do we're so
sorry and I'm like yeah but you're
looking at it like as if you did
something wrong you're saying in that
process that's like no it's like
sometimes people need to be reminded of
what you just said crime a customer and
it's like I'm not gonna be just
bulldozed and like you know you know it
the fact that the system set up to
bulldoze people that's what breaks my
heart well again a lot of look you you
lock your doors because you know there
are a few because of a few bad apples
yeah you know what I mean so you know so
for them to it was like oh man I
remember you remember did you ever work
for Pat Wilson now she sounds like a
fake name but she but she was this up
north Booker
yeah you know you did Pacific Northwest
and she caught herself acting like she
was giving putting you on a run but the
run would be like like less showers no
no no let's say like you won shows on
the third another shows on the the
seventh another shows on the 12th and
it's like you have to put yourself up so
I'm doing like colleges and stuff
in-between and I'm doing this too but
anyway alright so I'm doing a college
mmm and I'm doing a Indian casino in the
Pacific Northwest put lighting good
money Blair Witch Project okay but what
happened was the college is paying for
my rental car okay okay I send an email
I'm I think I'm talking to the college
hey thanks for the gig Bob uh but I was
told that I was gonna get reimbursed for
the rental car and I just wanna like I
accidentally sent that to the casino
okay
the casino guy hits me right back it
says like hey I don't think you should
talk to and I said oh my god I emailed
him right back
listen I am so sorry I was this is the
wrong legitimate mistake yeah you know
cuz in your emails they're all you know
hey you know this was all a part of the
same gig I send this the wrong thing
this was supposed to go to the college
my apologies this lady hits me up and
she's like are you trying to put you
were trying to pull a fast one on the
thing I said no if you could see the
email I I said to her I sent back yeah
you know the thing right away then she's
like you know well this is what I have
to deal with you know you know because
you know all the shady comics so now I'm
getting mad yeah you know well she's
coming from point of view of pain now
she's she's transferring that pain to
you and now we're gonna have a situation
now we have a situation cuz I wrote her
back and said hey it's not my
responsibility that you hire you know a
bunch of shady comics yeah you know me
that's all that's on you but anyway the
thing is it just turned into this this
thing this bag I never worked for again
yeah you know cuz I was like you know
you're like my thing was like hit me up
like yo first ask me hey what's up with
this situation with the rental car yep
and then I would have said right away
that was a mistake if you can see how
already but
for you to come at me right away cuz
she's coming from one of your pain that
I'm a criminal right that's what's
missing
yes so I said what I'm saying to you is
like I don't mind the initial like your
approach initially is fine yeah because
you're coming and being like hey this is
a situation yeah I think when they hit
you with the light they're shutting you
down from that point that's when you go
I gave it the college try
yes now it's like now I had to deal with
you on your footing yes give me your
[ __ ] man myself as I was doing I go
look I know it's not your thing but I go
there's something wrong with the country
I go customer service died with hip-hop
somewhere in the 90s you saw old say
that hip hop hip hop still good we just
found our cup of tea yeah dude it's not
supposed to be for me I'm old you know I
went I was uh I went to the GameStop you
know and I was buying something that
game starts a tremendous you know it but
it was like I love video games let you
see my xbox over there I have a gaming
channel Griffin gaming you know so some
I'm buying something like it's like the
like it's like you know how they rebuy
stuff yet from people then they resell
that staff so I bought something that
was like something was wrong with it so
I'm telling this young kid that works
there I said yeah this is and he's like
oh well that's not our responsibility
and I was like no this is your
responsibility and he's arguing me about
this and I said look dude if you were a
restaurant and you bought meat from a
butcher and that butcher and that
butcher showed you bad meat but you sold
it to your customers that's on you
yeah what you have to deal with with the
butcher is not my problem yeah you never
mean and so this guy you know he's and
then I was so mad and the manager comes
over and I but it's even worse sometimes
when you calmly that's a skip one of the
scariest things in life
dude that's calm or everybody try to
explain like here's the problem I'm
having right now
okay you know and it's like that's high
like to approach things like sometimes
I'll be like you know it's like you know
like you're dealing with something that
gets situation and I got I get to manage
over and I go you know this is your
fault yeah because I can tell that you
don't treat your employees properly
absolutely don'ts did the same thing you
jumped in on my brain again I was gonna
bring that up and I say you're not
treating your employees properly and
that's why they think it's okay to act
like this with me exactly it's the
transference of pain again like that's
why I say it's heartbreaking like I was
honestly thinking about starting a
podcast called bad company cuz I love
that bit bad company you know that song
to you you gotta grab this because if
when I can make a human connection with
somebody on the phone yeah like usually
if I can set the tone upfront one like
oh my god it's so great to talk to a
human being because a lot of these
companies now have these computer
systems hate it where you can't even
talk to somebody I'm the guy going there
zero to operator operator right so what
I fight it but it's they treat their
Cutler to their employees so poorly and
I don't feel like any word nobody feels
appreciated not the employees and not
the customer right and it's it's so the
people at the top can make even more
money and I find that I find that all
heartbreaking like imagine what our
unemployment would be in this country if
every company you'd personally just the
companies that touch your life hired the
right amount of customer service I know
I know
there'd be no unemployment yeah and if
they paid people properly like why does
some 60 or some 60 year old CFO CEO CMO
need to make 80 million a year so he can
be on a yacht with coke [ __ ] when they
could take that extra six let him take
twenty million and take that 60 million
and give it back to the people in the
trenches and let them let them have a
better life so then the customers get
treated better yeah you know you you're
but I don't know I don't know if
communism work stuff I don't think that
is communism
I think that's but I think that's better
long term capitalism because you know
what's gonna happen that's why I am a
capitalist because in a free market we
all
can vote with our dollars and you know
what unless you're gonna give me
customer service I'm gonna go somewhere
that has better business minds that's
gonna take care of their customers well
I'll tell you you mean first to take
care of their employees and then then
turn their employees we'll take care of
the customers well there are certain
companies like that because I take these
tech companies are like that
yeah because I went to the Facebook
campus they call it the campus
call up in San Francisco and I was just
I was just like this is amazing yeah you
know like because it's like the Health
Care's aren't you know they have their
own doctor on you know that kind of
thing they you know the food is free you
know it's just like it's just a distant
intramural sports yeah it's it's super
fun being in a rich kids basement you're
like what you can just get popcorn it
was a good when we just popped it it's
like you went to Richie Rich's house
yeah look at what and those companies
that take care of their employees
they're the ones making it all the money
yeah they thrive yeah so you think you
say yes oh we should extrapolate that
down to like smaller companies yeah
restaurants and things like that that's
why I what ever given the choice I'll
support a mom-and-pop business because
the customer service nine out of ten
times always better because it directly
the customers directly affect their
pockets yeah you know put when it's
corporate and corporate and layer of
bureaucracy but you would think like the
more corporate something is the more
they would have like you know they say
they have money to make sure things are
okay but it's just it's just not the
case and I can't stand going to a store
now where I have to be the checkout guy
oh you know it's like what is happening
everything and then you need I could
degree from the Learning Annex to figure
this [ __ ] out you know to call that one
person over that they saw him to come on
yeah there's doing that job now they
have to babysit 12 it's not just
scanning something yeah yeah uh oh my
god I can't stand that so much and every
app I have them like a now I'm my own
customer service yeah man oh it's true
what are you providing me I know that's
why I like it's like when you go to
Korean barbecue restaurant like you
can't complain about the cooking because
you're good
yeah it's I mean we tell we'll be back
with two cranky old guys after this
short break
cranky cranky but I do remember when you
felt like a customer I remember that and
it feels good like I still support
places that take care of me I'll go out
of my way to give them my money yeah you
do like little like you're like yes
Steve's the kind of guy that'll be like
there's this just you know you want to
do what the best Italian sub in the city
you're always that guy yeah that you
think you know the best sandwiches I'm
always training I'm always writing it
for I'll take tips this is the best
sandwich you know in LA you go to this
little places you know what cuz so many
times I've been to places and like I
built I do have that little kid optimism
about me where I build stuff up in my
brain I'm like this is gonna be awesome
just so disappointed yeah alright so
let's get back to you like so you're
you're you're in college and when did
you decide that like comedy comedy was
probably so I wound up getting a dream
job with the Philadelphia Eagles thought
it off as an intern oh man you had left
that corporate job you left the
corporate job told my parents I was
gonna go to law school cuz I like my
whole life I've always had that sort of
obligation to make them proud and I was
like maybe I'll be go to law school I
can postpone reality for a couple years
and then at least my mom could say her
son's a lawyer yeah but you would have
been one of those public defenders you
would have been one of those like you
know it's the only way Erin Brockovich
yeah I could be a sports agent as soon
as I got in there yeah like we got to
help this family and I started working
for a sports team and it was great but I
never lost that sort of bug in the back
of my brain cuz I did a couple open
mikes and then I did another open mic
and then I just got to the point where I
was so frustrated with life with all of
it mm-hmm that I was 27 I had been on
stage a handful of times and what that's
it I'm getting my car and I'm gonna
drive to the comedy store what was the
game plan yeah why the comedy store I
had two things that I had thought about
in LA like I I done my research and I
knew that second city
was now coming in Los Angeles right and
I was like all the people that made me
laughter on my childhood were either
second city guys Belushi Farley bill
Mary Harold Ramis so Mike I could take
classes at second city that's way cooler
than Law School and then I knew the
Comedy Store was the place for every
stand-up that I loved like I knew like I
would read what it'd be even before
podcasts before social there was less
information then but all the information
pretty much pointed in one direction for
stand-up that if if you're not
established there's one place to go and
they'll show you how to do it and that's
the Comedy Store
oh so I even went to triple-a and they
would give you those maps called a
triptych and the I started from my
parents house in suburban Philadelphia
right and then drove to our 84 33 sunset
that was the end point and oh wow how
long did that take it took like four
days you stopped and you liked seeing
America dude I remember the greatest
that must have been like such a great
journey a great adventure it was amazing
I felt almost like a Native American
manhood test because I used to be afraid
I used to be afraid to drive on the
freeway and stuff like that like all
nervous and then I remember looking
pulling out my map in Texas and going
I'm closer to LA that I am Philly Oh
legit the point of no return
I had a stinky car and almost like it's
not come about
yeah well going back and then I got to
LA with pretty much no money no credit
card no game plan and the simple fact
that I've survived the mine look singing
but so good and you do is you know it
was a great give me the thumbs up
whatever for I guess to go for this it'd
be my singing my but you got to turn it
on first then you hit mid spot
so I'll bet a point now where this
city's kicked my ass so much I'm just
grateful for surviving any any well
you're surviving man and you know you're
out here doing it it's just like it's
almost like you know you're so positive
that it's like weird you know yeah
people think there's something wrong
yeah yeah it's almost like but there's
like a like a naivety that they think
that you might have of I am ah Steve the
world doesn't work like that but you're
always fighting against that you're
always saying like no the world should
work like that right and I'm gonna
continue yes right yeah because I think
at our at our core people are amazing
and they want to connect and they want
to give back and they want to do the
right thing and I'm just trying to make
it easier for the people that I come
into contact with to do that oh well
said so let's uh I still I still like
hearing about this though you get to LA
you have no money what do you do what's
your first what's your first move
alright so in June I meet Pauly Shore
comes to Philly to host a stand-up
comedy contest oh I win the stand-up
comedy contest uh-oh
in Philly in Philly was that the TLA on
south street so I've been onstage maybe
10 times my whole life and that night I
was in front of like 800 900 people and
it worked so then Dean who later wound
up managing the Comedy Store wrote his
cell phone on a piece of paper and it's
like hey kid if you ever make it to LA
give me a call so I get to LA and then
it dawns me I have no game plan I'm now
I'm here yeah and I'm like the money I
thought was rent half of that went on a
hotel the first night and I I'm like I'm
in serious serious trouble
because my I pull in because there's
really not soon as you get like west of
Missouri yeah st. Louis I saw the arches
on the 10 or whatever was yeah then I
saw nothing
yeah there's nothing for three days yeah
and it's hard to putting life on that
journey oh yeah I'm just listening to
like that like Sunday night Drive music
where you're like you take the long way
: and I'm just trying to figure out life
and where I fit into it and and then I
remember coming in on the
ten and it must have been out by like
Ontario or something but you start to
come over the hill and then you see that
Los Angeles County base and I'm like oh
this is the real show yeah cars are
flying by me and I'm like what is hello
and I'm like I've heard of Melrose
Avenue do I get off here I'm like this
is not the right neighborhood and I
remember my first stop was the Saharan
Motor Lodge across from rock and roll
Ralph oh that's still there I think
he'll there Oh God and it was like a
hooker spot oh I think it was that it
was I walked into that a hotel I paid
for the hotel and it smelled like death
like literally like maybe somebody did
die in there was that the moment that
you thought I did I make a mistake the
moment was no just being on the freeway
and having everybody cut me off okay and
by me and now I feel like I'm in a video
game yeah and I'm like oh I should have
planned this right and then I I I got
this cheap motel and then I demanded my
money back I was a sir I'm like nope
give me the money now that's disgusting
I mean I was like yeah yeah and I stayed
at the Best Western across from the
Comedy Store oh right but that was like
peak summer tourists oh yeah years ago
well that's still pretty nice now yeah
dude it was like 200 bucks there oh my
god
if from one night oh then I'm like what
am I gonna do yeah and I jelly $275 I
had about a thousand box right right
right
and then I went the Mel's and I called a
buddy of mine that graduated with my
younger brother who was living who had
just moved out two months prior and we
spoke once or twice on the phone and he
was like if you make it out of here just
give me a call and I did and he let me
crash on his couch for two weeks
oh no and I you know death you just
start working the phone yeah yeah and
then like my younger brother had another
friend in Manhattan Beach who was like
there's a great wings place in Santa
Monica and they make the best pizza so I
go in there and the kid I first got in
LA with my buddy Jules who's from Jersey
who took pity on me and of and it was
like you want to
job I'm like yes so I start delivering
pizza within a week of getting a low bow
and then he was like where he's staying
he goes my buddy's moving out of a place
you can rent a room and you can take
over his room in this three bedroom so I
live with strangers for about six months
it's still the nicest place I've lived
in but I'm still trying to get to the
life that I had when I moved out here 20
years ago Steve's out there still
looking for a good room guys right so
and just that was it and then I remember
calling Dean again and he was like look
Pauly's shooting this movie called Pauly
Shores dead Jew I can get you a job
doing craft services so I would do craft
services during the day deliver pizzas
at night and then I had two or three day
jobs for about my first nine ten years
well in comedy and then Tommy started to
give me main room spots at the store cuz
I told him I go Tommy
this one hundred bucks I can make in the
main room is this it's a lot it's I go
that's in a week in a month like if
you're gonna make it that's like $400
right which is like 80 90 hours working
minimum wage but yeah yeah you you
worked at the door - I worked every job
at the store right so I went from doing
craft services and moving furniture and
stuff on the set of paulie's movie
Paulie sure I remember that phone call
that changed my life we worked from 6
a.m. one day to about 2:30 in the
morning and the other piays really
weren't doing anything and I got so
pissed that it wasn't a full couch but
it was like a little two-seater loveseat
and I'm like screw this and I just
carried it by myself down a flight of
steps and as I'm carrying it down the
steps by myself Paulie was coming up the
steps and it was like isn't anybody
helping but he was how come nobody's
helping you on him because they don't
want to work oh oh you were that guy now
I was pissed you were [ __ ] Rudi you
were real in the morning go in the
morning and these other idiots are like
smoking pot more
oh you with you with that kid you're out
we're here to work but I was pissed
well that's how I grew up like well I
like I didn't grow up in but I grew up
in Delaware County Pennsylvania which is
essentially where lawyers and
construction workers become neighbors
yeah that's and it was like no matter
what you did you worked that's it you go
to work and he called me that when I got
home it was like three o'clock in the
morning
what's Pauli one and he goes dude I
appreciate how hard your work and he
goes I'm gonna make sure you get a job
at The Comedy Store so then that was the
that was my first big break because then
I got a job answering phones at the
Comedy Store which meant I'd have to go
through that open mic process anymore so
I could now have three minutes of stage
time every week oh I mean just listen no
you what you just said you know it's
like people that like the people that
don't really want to do the work to do
comedy to people that want to skip the
steps the people that don't want to line
the shortcuts you can take the shortcuts
and eat because they because they would
hear that and be like that's it but I
understand how important that was at
that particular time yeah because at
that time this was the open mic this is
how crazy the open mic process at this
store was they would put a list out on
Saturday night the only night the club
was having any business in those days
right oh really
and they would put it the club was so
slow the front bar was never opened the
front gardens start to open up to like
2011 2012 so this is really yeah from
part so the front bars closed
they put a list out 40 crazy people open
my comics half of them were homeless
would show up scare away the business
that was there to write their name on a
list on Saturday night which meant you
had to find a parking space try to find
a meter on the Sunset Strip on a
Saturday night or spend 10 bucks to park
your car to write your name on the list
then you would have to come back the
next day Sunday afternoon to draw
numbers out of a bucket to see if you
got a spot we could do a spot the
following Sunday
so it was a three-day commitment for a
three-minute spot and it and the gas and
the pay for parking yeah so that three
minutes of stage time was everything and
then my car blew up on me so the first
eight years in comedy that 3-minute open
mic was pretty much the only stage time
I got unless somebody took me out on the
road Wow
gee whiz yeah so then I you know I got
in at the store I started answering
phones three months later they made me
the manager and then you were why did I
not I did not know this yeah from like
March of 2001 to about I don't know
maybe the following at least a year and
I knew it the job I wanted was door guy
and I even when I managed I would still
answer the phones the shifts nobody
wanted because that was usually the
first shift of the day so you go from
like 10:00 a.m. to 1:00 or 2:00 on the
phones until somebody wanted to come
into work and then I would drive from
the store back to the pizza place start
delivering pizzas and then they made me
the manager of the club so the only
nights I didn't work for Friday and
Saturday so then I could deliver they
were big money nights delivering pizzas
Fridays and Saturdays so you just being
the manager of the Comedy Store wasn't
like enough money give me light would be
like okay now I can you know what I got
paid what $75 a shift no better manager
no benefits oh my god no benefits no
overtime I would have to come in there
was a point where I would they
eventually split my job up into multiple
jobs and then the as soon as I became a
door guy the next guy they hired for 20
bucks an hour and benefits and I'm like
really how many times am I gonna kick ya
you might have still stayed at that job
though right and that's why I accept it
all yeah and door guy I was Duncan's
assistant so it's the assistant talent
coordinator I worked the parking lot
like twice before I had enough the cover
booth was an easy fun job yeah
Matisse's system was legendary oh wow I
got like I knew then it was something
special but now I look back on it and
I'm like oh I got to form a close
personal relationship with the woman
that made stand-up comedy stand-up
comedy Wow I would how was that how was
that oh wow
she had fired everybody uh-huh this is
one she I mean she was feared it seemed
like what people don't realize and part
of her legend as it's growing is that
she was a straight-up gangster she would
like I remember once like one of my
first memories of Mitzi was watching her
sit in that chair in the back of the
room yeah and calling somebody over and
pointing to the guy that was managing
that night she goes fire and they were
quiet let him go he's too tall she fired
a dude just because he was too tall he's
blocking everybody and I don't want to
have to look up at him Don sorry did
there goes your dreams I wonder where
that guy is probably fish and what
marlin fishing with the Cuban going I
got the commercial real estate so I
remember the rumors world Mitzi's
looking for another assistant don't let
it be you everybody was like don't say
no if they offered it to you don't do it
she'll let you last two days and she
would fire you one of two ways she'd
fire you and we'll still loved you which
meant you could still be a part of the
club right or she would fire you and
don't don't ever let me see your friends
want to see that guy ever again yeah so
I was nervous
but then I was already I was already him
with the shore family excited man it's
the club Paula I had worked for Paulie
his brother period Peter liked me I was
already in and then it was like how
about Steve and she was like oh I guess
yeah give me my Stevie and here's the
weird thing I never knew until later on
that she actually liked me right because
or else she would have just gotten rid
of me
yeah yeah how'd you last
over a year year-and-a-half oh wow that
that's a that's a long time yeah and she
kept her thumb on me she got like four
all of it like so this is this is I get
brought into the comedy stores Pauly's
guy
the comedian he found in Philly who he
thinks is gonna be a star right right
Emmet's he's like no maybe we'll let him
work the phones Yeah right he'll be the
manager of the club you'll be my
assistant a star No
so then I saw I'm working all the jobs
now I've become her her assistant which
means I would take the bus from my
apartment in Hollywood to the comedy
store pick up the Comedy Store van
called Mitzi's house see what she needed
Tommie story at her van but yeah now
they're using as a merch thing was a
gray van with all the names painted on
oh wow
and then I drive to her house and get
her out of bed most days that's how it
that's how it would be every once in a
while she were to be awakened downstairs
but usually I get her out of bed get her
dressed walk her down the steps like she
had this because he was obviously sick
at the time yeah so it was more
caregiver than assistant and she would
treat me like a dog bro like she would
watch TV like this and have me sit next
to her and she would just be like go get
me a cookie
oh yeah oh yeah but this is when it like
but then every once in a while some
wisdom would come up and I remember like
I knew of the legend the Mitzi shore
that's why I was getting to the Comedy
Store but I remember once when I was
like oh this is somebody special and I
should have asked her for it I know she
would have given it to me
she loved me but she had Richard Pryor's
book on her coffee legit coffee table
book on her coffee table prior
convictions and I opened it up and it
said two mitts he loved Richard was
something else was and it was after Ms
started to affect Richard but it was
like a beautiful inscription like none
of us would have happened without you
right right right and I'm like that's
Jenna that's now stand up comedy got
born real stand-up was her relationship
with Richard so every once in a while to
get one of those stories every once in a
while I'm driving her to the doctor's
like we got really close at some point
like where I'm like oh I'm dead II
definitely getting passed like I would
have to drive her over the showcases at
the Comedy Store like one of my favorite
stories I've told this before but this
is before I'm her assistant I remember
it was the worst advice I ever gave
myself because every because I had
started to kill at the employee spot on
the open every was like dude you have to
get past yeah yeah and everybody's like
that's a weird spot to be into yes and
everybody's going all right we're gonna
put you on the showcase list I got from
Philly drew that by the way but go on
past
he's from Philly I was gonna turn on the
singing mic and try to do a boys
dimension so uh I remember going alright
this is it
this is your moment you're gonna have
three minutes on stage in front of the
godmother kill it and the truth was
Sunday nights would be showcase night
was also the night Sex in the City came
on so there was a 90% chance she was
gonna cancel and stay in and watch Sex
in the City ha ha
so you get on the showcase lists there
were comics that their best source of
stage time during those years was being
on mitzi showcase list because sometimes
it would last for months where they
could show up every Sunday they were on
the showcase right when I have a seven
minute spot or a three-minute spot
they're like bro I'm on the list but she
didn't show up so I'm like I had a
couple those Sunday's for her she didn't
show up and then one night I walk into
the room and there's three people and
I'm like I'm glad she didn't show up and
they're like no mitts he called she's on
her way and I'm like how are you gonna
showcase in front of three people
that's all you that's not just do what
you do and I came out all high-energy
like I used to cut I was opening up for
Paulie at the time and I would come out
like an 80s heavy metal singer let me
see your cigarette lighters and if
here's the Vegas Schmitz he likes you
she would circle your name right if she
didn't like you she'd scratch on him off
the list so there's three people in the
audience
she's in the back of the room and I'm
like just do what you do and I attacked
the stage cuz I'd seen documentaries on
pallucci and stuff and what was the
guy's name del clothes is like you have
to attack the stage right I'm gonna
attack the stage Bellucci style I
grabbed the mic and I go what's up y'all
Santana's let me see your cigarette
lighters and it was so quiet in the room
you could hear her and I'm like my
dreams aren't happening tonight and then
it's like two years after that I'm
killing it with Mitzi and I would drive
her I know I'm the guy driving her to
the showcases right next door yeah and I
were driving her home and I'm like so
did you see anybody you like tonight
what did you like to know and I were a
couple of times where my name would be
circled or she'd have my name circled
with stars around it or she'd have a
little note next to my name but she
never passed me and uh she don't want to
lose you I thought and in hindsight and
this might be what's that complex people
get when they get like taken prisoner
Awards back home so yeah this might be
Stockholm Syndrome for you for me yeah
I'm so far enough to think that one
could be Stockholm but I honestly I'm
like people think I'm a little naive now
imagine me 15 oh I know I know that's
what I'm saying I I I'm there with you
right now I know that this is like what
you must have thought was gonna happen
what'd he do like you know it was like
you know we will your thought process is
like yeah I know how she was giving me
tough love yeah she was protecting me
from the business she was she was needed
it you still need it yeah she was she
was she was making me tough hmm and I'm
grateful for that I'm grateful for that
because there was one time this is how I
got fired so everyday I'm hanging out
with her like she tell me a story about
somebody that I grew up loving on TV and
that's great and then like you know she
always told me Gary Shandling was the
nicest guy in the world and still sent
her flowers on her birthday and then one
day I'm at the doctor's office with her
and I'm welcomed by and I see Shandling
on the
dr. Sabol so I go back and I sit next to
Mitty dome it's you'll never guess who's
here who your buddy Gary Gary yeah your
buddy Gary Shandling she goes whoa
send him in I go why she goes tell him
it's me okay hey mister Shandling and
I'm wearing the dorky comedy store short
uh comedy store I go yeah actually
admits he's right next door is cheap she
would love it if he could come by and
say hi and he goes I'll be right over
and then I see Shandling and Mitzi
ketchup for the first time in years they
talked maybe two three hours the doctor
just let them have their own room and
I'm just a fly on the wall for that
conversation between two legends oh so
there was really positive memories like
that and then there were times like I
hate her she's the workhorse she fired
me because Paulie had me re and rent is
easy do you ever hear this story no oh
this is comedy store folklore because
she could be in the coffee table book
for the like because we were the last
like she passed other comics after us
but I would say we were the last three
she really had her thumb on oh god she
does that make sense yeah I know she
passed Whitney and de Leon aye she
passed me
she passed you but like we were the ones
that she was like we were tortured by
her right and and in my brain Mitzi
shore was like PI May from Kill Bill
that's breaking assassins yeah
breaking your balls breaking you want to
take her eye out yeah like I remember
when you were telling that story about
the different types of dudes in the
military I got to see behind the curtain
on my last USO tour and I got to talk to
a Marine drill instructor and those
dudes are as hard as nails but now we're
not kids he's not a kid we're having
beers after a comedy show and he was the
reason why we break their balls like
that is to keep them alive
yeah when bullets are flying if I don't
instill in them the skills they need
they will die so now I'm able to see
that drill instructor vibin Mitzi shore
okay so this is one of the ways she this
is how she broke our balls so I'd been
her assistant like a year and a half she
knew my whole backstory she knew Paulie
brought me into the club
the
only times she would ever let me get a
break from being her assistant was when
I was on the road opening up for Paulie
and then I'd come back and she would
have already thought if I was gone a
week four different people came and went
in that way my [ __ ] house for real
you're dead to me like like legit yeah
um so Paulie thinks he's gonna do us a
favor it's me re run is easy at the time
Paulie sister sandy was running a room
in Palm Springs called sandy shores
comedies see box or something oh Jesus
yeah I did class by the way famous
comedy sandbox well so we're like it's
Friday we drive out we fight all that
traffic it's me are earrin is easy we
have a hotel room run is easy in fact
dudes always been like the straw that
stirs the drink like guys you wanna have
a couple cocktails we'll go tables we'll
do the shows always so we show up at the
club and uh the lady at the time that
was managing the club was Shelly and she
pops backstage Malachy
what are you doing here and she goes hey
guys Paulie have your mom in the back of
the room we're like what so Paulie goes
hey I invited my mom to the show tonight
so she could see you guys in front of a
real crowd he was like sometimes my mom
just needs to see you in front of a real
live audience and not some open mic in
the or when it's deaf oh gosh she goes
that's how Bobby Lee got past Bobby was
opening up for me in Vegas my mom never
thought he was funny until she saw Bobby
kill whatever so now Ari and run is
easier like yes this is gonna be great
they're already riding high I
immediately go this is not gonna I knew
I had a feeling you spent too much time
with her - yes and then also by this
point the closer I got to her the more
impossible it became for me to have a
good set in front of her it's kind of
like if you see a hot chick but you
don't know her you're like I don't care
and then you get her laugh and all you
but then you like if the hot chicks your
best friend and you bill
up in your mind and you're like I'm
imagining us with a beach house one day
and grandkids coming over and I'm making
meatballs and you can't even talk to the
girl right raise the stakes so uh I'm
looking at them and I go alright here's
the deal I go I've never had a good set
in front of me I go I'm I go I'll take
the bullet cuz we were all going who's
gonna go first who said I'll go on first
and they're like really
am I getting let's do it and I think I
want me re Ren it's easy I think that's
all I know I went on first and I'm like
I really I felt like I was that dude
running towards the bullets or I'm like
I just want you guys to get home to your
families so I go well I'm not
exaggerating very few times in my career
have all the stars lined up where you
just catch lightning I go out and murder
oh wow murder out of out of the yangtze
spot and run is easy it's like you are
like as I'm bringing out like
congratulations you just got passed yeah
I might kill it re kill what it's like
it was inspired me I'm like he's right
into the mic yeah he kills it run as
easy kills it now we're all trip always
on stage and they're all they're all
ready so they're popping champagne in
the seventh inning on the plastic wrap
way little do they know they're worth
they're wearing a Buffalo Bills Super
Bowl championship sure alright so I'm
going I don't know they're like what do
you mean on run Azizi smoking cigarettes
what do you mean his money to go play
blackjack I go hey man I just I don't
have a good feeling about this like you
do junior had too much yeah yeah Shelly
Delly comes back like and I like mitts
he wants to talk to you guys and
remedies like see I told you we're about
to get past and I don't know it's not
gonna be good she looks at us and she
goes Steve's right it's not good
so we're in the back of this comedy club
she's sitting in her chair looking up at
us immediately Arion run as easy fall to
the knees Oh Smitty what up she was
listening to me and then she looks at me
you I'm so mad at this point like what
the [ __ ] do you think that was a noise
like up stand-up comedy we up we all
just a great shut up you think you did
great well objectively the audience yet
you're not ready for the road
she goes you're not ready for the road
until I say you're ready for the road
and she points to me she goes you how
many names are on that van you drive me
around then I'm like I want she goes
tell me how many signatures on there and
I'm like I don't know that's right you
don't know you don't know [ __ ] she goes
you know what all those signatures have
in common they're all millionaires you
want to know why they're millionaires
cuz they did it my way she cuz you want
to go get lost out on the road and
become a nobody what do you want to sit
down shut up and listen to me she was
you're not ready for the road until I
say you're ready for the road so I'm
like there was a tiny little glimmer of
hope in me that night right because it
was the first time I heard her refer to
me as hers and I would he also has a
also a comic yes yes and I would hear
rumors like she would check in should we
check him with but now I'm her assistant
and a door guy right I'm not or
answering phones I'm not the manager but
you would ask the managers like how
Steve doing on his spots how's this and
she like she had her thumb on me little
bit you check in ask but I'm like oh
maybe she does care kind of a little bit
and then I that was on Friday and I came
to the Kotok the bus to the Comedy Store
on Monday and I caught by that point she
had an overnight caregiver Alfred and I
call Alfred to get her grocery lists
he's like bitsy what do you need from
the store uh-huh uh-huh and I'm like
what she need Alfred
she said nothing from you man you hear a
screaming uh don't come in she's still
screaming you're fired and I got fired
for opening up for Paula Oh No yeah
which I don't know I guess yeah I guess
that was her way of saying like hey just
go cut your teeth a little bit more and
then about two years after that three
months maybe it would you'd stoop now
still getting spots at the store this
point I'm not a paid regular yet all
right this is like 2003-2004 really
don't become a paid regular to 2008 took
me eight years and I remember around I
guess we were around the same time then
yeah this why okay these are two great
Mitzi things I remember once she she was
having an issue where sometimes she
would fall out of bed and call the store
for help when Alfred wasn't there I
don't know if I was living there all
right but uh I was convinced she hated
me and Tommy's on the phone with her Oh
Tommy yeah and he's like wow mitts yeah
I have to run the club I can't come get
you and she's like well who's there and
he was like I could send any just
looking in the room shouting out names
and I'm talking to Tommy in the cover
booth and I'm like she's not gonna want
me to go get her and then he goes won't
Steve Simone's here and then I hear her
voice go yeah send me my Stevie and oh
my god so now she's not this mythical
matriarch of comedy that's breaking my
balls
she's just an older woman that needs my
help just my friend Ramon yeah I mean
all right I'm gonna go oh god I mean she
was all I found her on the floor you
know and I put her into bed and we just
started talking like she's I used to
have to talk her asleep like I used to
do a bit about my little brother and how
he would fall asleep talking but the
reason I wrote that bit is because I
would do it to Mitzi and it reminded me
of my little brother like Mitzi would be
like and then John Witherspoon showed up
[Music]
and then I tip them turn out tonight put
a sleep
you know so then we start talking and
she said all these really cool things
about how much she believed in me and my
car and then I didn't get passed I think
that was probably like 2007
zarbor I but that at that point too
though Tommy had his fingers and
everything again well this is what
happened out of it right so now I'm
hanging out with Aria again and I had
stayed away from the store for about a
year because I was just working the road
non-stop I was doing a bunch of military
stuff and then at the time Steve Trevino
was my roommate he just started to
headline so he was like getting a ton of
dates and I was his roommate so he was
like I'll let you feature on these dates
so I know you can pay your rent so it
was a great great it was cool back then
so cool yeah so uh I was probably there
was one year like 2006 ish or I think I
was on the road 40 some weeks out of the
year it was crazy
yeah cuz he he was big dude see yeah
yeah that stuff so I was doing a ton of
stuff with him and I will say this
before I got passed in Hollywood I don't
remember the year but remember mitts he
always used to give me loya I'd get paid
in la jolla and bro she had me down
there all that yeah yeah she'd let me
emcee number one show imagine this for a
show in La Jolla the weekend Chelsea
Handler's book came out so it was like
right before she blew up with she was
doing La Jolla to promote the sale of
her book right the lineup was mm seeing
Sebastian is featuring and Chelsea
Handler headlines oh wow and I knew then
that was gonna be a legendary show not
because I was like I'm like oh these are
the shows people talk about so I'm on
the road like a year Tommy calls me they
would still even though I hadn't worked
at the club as a doorman or whatever for
a year and a half or something it would
still give me the friends-and-family
spot on Sunday nights my three minutes
because I had to earn that after five
years of slave labor and then Mitty was
conscious you know I said I got hyah
spots but I'm talking to Ari I hadn't
seen him in awhile because I've been on
the road so much and I'm like I'm just
done Mike I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
yeah
one thousand eight cuz I think we're
just meeting each other around this time
yes and was back when I just sit at the
waitress table in the back
I will go down there to hang out even
though I wasn't performing and me and
Ari are talking in the phone rings and
it's Tommy inside me and I are talking
about the store and I'm asking him about
everybody and I'm like oh my god it's
the comedy store as I get it so I Steve
it's Tommy mitts he wants to know if you
want to showcase for this Sunday and I
are is right there and I just got done
saying how I was yeah yeah so I go nah
cuz I'm like I can't lose my face in
front re and he goes what do you mean
now because you don't want to showcase
from it see and I don't know and he goes
but you've worked so hard for it and I
go yeah but she's always said no so I
don't give a [ __ ] anymore
he goes well might I ask why and I go
it's kind of like being a girl's best
friend and she's hooking up with every
other guy that treats her like [ __ ] yeah
and then uh you eventually stop wanting
to date her I go that's me in the comedy
story you guys who treated me like [ __ ]
for eight years I don't need it it was
well let me ask you a question well if
Jamie Masada cuz I'd already started to
headline one offset improv at that point
okay nine Brian yeah yeah um he goes if
Jamie Masada called you would you go
showcase for Jamie I know yeah
absolutely well why would you showcase
for Jamie and not Mitya go cuz I was
never Jamie's assistant I never got
Jamie out of bed and put him in the bed
for almost two years I never managed
Jamie's club and ever parked cars for
Jamie I never mix drinks for Jamie it
was like well I'm sorry you hear that I
go yeah well I'm sorry that I have to
say it and he goes well I I guess if you
want to do those employees spots still
I'm more than willing to keep you on the
list I'm like whatever dude
okay maybe boom and they're always like
whoa I mean yeah whoa thank you guys I
guess you had to do that I go I guess so
I know it felt good I'm like I stood up
for myself
you know yeah so I was like if she
doesn't think I'm funny by now she's
ever gonna think I'm Rui Rui Rui right
but the thing was wasn't about being
funny it was about having the balls to
do that yeah yeah yeah so now me and Ari
are talking the phone rings again and
it's Tommy you go Steve I just got off
the phone with Mitty and I'm like uh-huh
what did she want Wow she said to tell
you something I'm like what
congratulations you are you're our
newest paid regular and then our it was
like this is great uh I got past but I
was so pissed by that point I didn't
even wanna the only reason I stayed at
the Comedy Store after that tumultuous
time period was that I needed the 15
bucks they were paying us at the time
she that's how broke I was yeah I'm
going all right I could do a spot
Wednesday and put gas in my car for a
week at the time yeah well that's great
man crazy right I know and that's my
plot around the time that I got passed I
got past life's 2007 2006 some yeah I
think like you were passed before me I
remember yeah I was could you just
showed up good you were one of those
guys that developed outside of the
comedy store yeah but it still was like
it was still uh it was still a thing
like dealing with Tommy was a thing yeah
you know he was like he didn't make it
whatever I whatever you went through
with her on a smaller level oh I went
through with Tom had you through with
him yeah absolutely like I never you
never knew what was coming from Mitte
what was coming yeah so it was like you
don't who knew but I remember the night
okay there was two nights for me one of
them was like I remember the night what
three nights actually the first night I
ever showcase for her was in the Oh our
mm-hmm and uh I met him at at the time I
set it up for me yeah you know she
didn't even look at Jay Davis got passed
the night that okay and so I was
infuriated you know I mean cuz I didn't
even talk to me like literally she just
looked ahead I wouldn't understand
standing next to the boom people are
going cold yeah yeah didn't even look at
me all right sounds like [ __ ] yeah it
wasn't like a year or so later that like
they started doing showcases in the main
room remember was that the Barry cat
stuff no they were doing showcases in
the main room doing like one of Vargus
and Kathy
okay so they just did it so they brought
her in she's sitting in that booth yeah
but at that time I was like I [ __ ]
this but I really was at that point
because I was just tired of all the
[ __ ] tried to run around tommy was
giving me
yeah so I'm on stage you're supposed to
do like a few minutes I was like [ __ ]
you as much time as I [ __ ] won that's
what I thought in my head yeah you know
and I ran the light I was like I love
I'm doing this [ __ ] you know I'm killing
this crowd so I was like cuz I was
thinking to myself let me show you what
how this is supposed to really be done
yes you want to see what I can do you
know so then I'm now standing in the
hallway next to the a kid like where you
go into the kitchen yep so they bring
her out of that little door and he sees
me and she says you were funny and then
they took her out and then she they
walked her out and then Tommy
mountaintop and then Tommy comes then
sometime he goes all right you know
you're you're you're in I feel like that
she really passed me by
that's it yeah but Tommy made it like we
gotta go to the belly room you know now
you're in the belly room for like a year
or like whatever it was sounds like okay
I didn't believe that [ __ ] but I was
like okay Tommy whatever so I did a
belly room for a year I still not I paid
regular yeah I refer ever spot I got I
refused to park in the lot even though I
was allowed to I said I'm never parking
in this lot until I'm a paid regular
okay so I parked down the street pay $10
whatever I had to do yeah and I said I'm
not parking in this lot till I feel like
I until I feel like I earned it and so
then it was like I I don't walk through
the back door my jujitsu school yet
boom I walked through the front door all
the good guys walk you understand we're
the same cut from the same so I remember
the night it was like really late eight
people in the crowd
Steve Trevino I don't think he was
passed yet either okay he goes up before
me and he's bitter he's angry about it
you know you remember how he was - you
know him he's like you know you give
daddy - daddy that one o'clock a.m. spot
you know daddy can't shine right now
he's doing all this [ __ ] yeah he's
saying all this nonsense to the crowd
that's you know I'm next
yeah you know so I'm like all right so
when I
go up I give these [ __ ] that 9
p.m. show yep
it'll work Oh Tommy come sign the
paperwork tomorrow you know yoga your
now pay regular Wow
you know and I was like so I don't know
if I've ever even told Steve that but I
know it was because it was that I needed
that I needed him to be so like anti
what was happening yet having the crowds
yeah you know that I needed that and
then you know so I did that so and
that's not that's when I became a paid
regular and then you know it says I had
a goal of yours I mean it was like you
grow up here right at a certain point it
was like at a certain point I thought it
was important but then it became a thing
where I was like [ __ ] this place
well that was like I don't realize you
know what was dead during those years to
dead dead like sometimes it wouldn't
even be a show dad Tommy's just
resurrecting it and it's like that's
when Sebastian Bret Ernst and John
copper willow and these guys are they're
making their rise and they're doing
they're doing belly room spots then it
would go Whitney Chris me or me Whitney
Chris or like I was doing belly room
spots on Tuesdays with Whitney and Chris
yeah
that's you know I I he did see Chris was
right before he Chris was before me with
that he was doing those belly moon spots
and him and I were doing sets at the
haha and all these kind of places and I
didn't realize what he was doing at the
Comedy Store so when I found out I was
like I need to get over there and that's
what I did that I did that because of
that you know but I got to a point where
I was like [ __ ] this I don't care and
what was happening I was being around
the Comedy Store a lot and I'd be
sitting there talking with someone and
it Tommy would walk by and that person
would go like Tommy do you know Eric you
know you got to get him in here now and
I'd look at Tommy and be like this is
immediate I'm trying to asking you about
this so I'm not gonna so it I just
waited for my time to happen you know
yeah but it's like you know I look back
on all that and even when Tommy left you
know there was a there was a part of me
that was like I was like oh there was a
method to the madness all of him even if
he didn't consciously know what it did
for me yes I appreciated beautiness yeah
struggle with this struggle and like I
have a very special relationship
you know I'll give him a phone call I
have no hard feelings I have nothing but
love for the dude listen I don't have
any hard feelings you know I was there
the day he first walked into the
building oh really
uh-huh that's crazy I just realized I
saw Tommy the day he walked in to try to
get a job and then I saw Tommy the night
he was let go oh wow so I'm at the post
/ go full circle but like I say I don't
have any feel feel in it and I think
that he thinks I do I've just I've just
heard things but if you do you since
you'd you still talk to him you should
let him know I have no ill feelings you
know what that you know what this is a
good lighter me yeah yeah I think we I
think we did some good way we did some
good talking on this episode right now
and so I want to thank you for coming on
and once again what's the name of your
album Java job look for Java on iTunes
or any way you can find comedy albums
I'm sure it's everywhere I'm sure it's
Amazon everyplace like that I have links
in the description and this is my good
friend Steve Simone we're trying to
listen we're working on projects
together we're trying to get some stuff
sold and because we want to buy
chick-fil-a's and retire the funniest
guy going you need a refill Matt yeah
yeah you work here but they don't know
now I actually own the place but I'm not
gonna tell ya we're just trying to
ensure customer service is good you know
what I mean so but this is my again my
what's my good buddy Steve Simone and I
really thank you for coming on and
you'll probably see him again on other
episodes because yeah you're the best
man and like if you really want I got to
reiterate if you want some some positive
comedy if you wanna that's if you don't
if you don't want to just all just laugh
at the negative things in life which a
lot of comics do including myself but if
you want to celebrate life and celebrate
some of the good times this is the man
to listen to my good buddy Steve Simone
and that's I've been another episode of
referent with Griffin make sure you
subscribe smash that like smash that
reminder and keep listening and you'll
have all the description in the
description you can find all about Steve
and thanks again and I'll see you guys
on the flip side thanks for listening
[Music]